[Music]
mark starts off this hour in chattanooga
hey mark welcome to the ramsey show
hey how you doing
uh better than your phone what's
up that's better mark yes that's better
sorry so my question is i'm doing baby
steps i'm on number two i'm
self-employed it's just me sole
proprietor and um my accountant is
telling me that i'm on track this year
to end up on the irs from between five
and six grand
he's saying if you're thinking about
buying a truck for your business this is
the time to do it so you'll have that at
the ride off instead of painting into
the irs but he doesn't really
explain it in a way that i can
understand it um he's a good accountant
but he can't explain anything very well
so is this a good move or not
that's a great question were you
planning on buying a truck mark
not really i have a truck it is getting
old
but it's still good enough
okay
uh mark i've got really bad news
you need to fire your accountant
he's an idiot
okay let me let me tell you why he's an
idiot here's the math
if you buy a thirty thousand dollar
truck and write it off over three years
you get to write off ten thousand
dollars a year
if you're in a twenty 25 tax bracket
that saves you two thousand five hundred
dollars in taxes
in year one two and three
okay
and so you just wrote a thirty thousand
dollar check to uh offset a 2 500
expense and oh by the way you have a 5
000 expense so you have to buy a 60 000
truck to offset 5k this year
this guy's a [ __ ] okay
okay
that's dumb okay you follow me that's
just dumb now if you need a 60 000 or 30
000 or 10 000 truck for your business
because you can make more on your
business as a result of having invested
in equipment that is the only time in
business that we buy things we do not
ever buy things solely for the write-off
because a write-off is a tax deduction
not a tax credit meaning that you take a
if i do a 10 000 expense and i'm in a 25
tax bracket it saves me 2 500 i'm
trading a dollar for a quarter
not a good trade
okay i might okay mark i feel that i
feel the the wheels turning go back to
what you just said at the very beginning
dave go slow in that when you said you'd
have to buy a 30 000 because it's not a
credit it's not like oh you can use you
have to write off 5 000 so you could go
get a 5 000 truck and have it paid for
for the taxes you were you know what i'm
saying like your taxes never pay for the
item
ever
because you get a tax deduction
which means the amount of money that you
spend on the item in business is expense
if it's a business expense
comes off of your taxable income
so you're gonna if you if you spend ten
thousand dollars on an item for business
then that means you don't pay taxes on
ten thousand dollars of your income
because you just expensed it
you did not make as much profit
in other words you follow me
got it
and so what it does is it saves you the
taxes on the ten thousand dollars which
would be about twenty five hundred
dollars three thousand dollars
something like that it does not save you
ten thousand dollars so there's no time
in the equation ever that you put out
ten thousand dollars and it saves you
ten thousand dollars in taxes
there's only one time that happens and
it's one percent of the time it's called
a tax credit and it never applies to
these situations that we're talking
about here and so anytime your
accountant tells you people out there in
the world that have a business that you
need to go buy something to save on
taxes
he or she is saying
please it is my advice for you to go
trade a dollar for a quarter
okay now if you want to need to buy
something for your business again
separate discussion
not taxes but you want to if you want to
spend money on your business and it's
going to make you more than it costs you
that's called an investment and that's
what we always do in business
and i spent more than ten thousand
dollars probably in the last few minutes
here and i don't even know what i did
with it around this place but and mark
two i would say earlier too when you
mentioned that he can't explain stuff to
where you can really understand that's
an issue too and that's true with your
investment professional that you're
working with that's true with your
insurance tax pros i mean anyone that's
in these really niche parts of your life
and your money that
save or cost you a lot
and handle that part you really want to
know the ins and outs so the fact that
he keeps talking over your head and you
can't just use layman terms to sit there
and explain it to me
that's that's a big red flag too so the
kind of investment you do is you go okay
if we had an extra truck
uh we could make another hundred
thousand dollars a year
because that truck would generate that
much revenue the fact that we had that
truck would help us generate revenue if
you can make an extra 100 000 a year and
you want to spend twenty thousand
dollars and you have twenty thousand
dollars in cash and buy a truck well you
do that all day long okay can i ask you
this so i was on instagram i know i know
i know we're about to go down this
rabbit hole prepare your hearts everyone
and it was on uh like in your algorithm
there's like a part that just like feeds
you content right that you just look up
and it's just random stuff other stuff
you've looked at so it's sending you
crap because you had previously been to
crap sites i don't know maybe or it says
oh they like this so this this this okay
so
one of mine came up and it said on the
screen and it was a real so you could
see it was a video and it said something
like the smartest the smartest purchase
um rich people make and it's a private
plane on the real so i was like oh
that's fascinating so i click on it and
basically the the guy was saying
one of the smartest ways for people one
of the smartest and i don't know if you
use the word investments purchases
for
rich people to make are private planes
because they can write it off within
their business it's not the luxury end
it's not the
convenience but they can write it off so
again i know we're talking about a truck
and i just jumped over like yeah you
jumped you jumped to a jet i jumped like
way ahead i know but same philoso with
that would that be because you can only
write it off to the extent you use it
for business and so if a rich person buy
has a business and they buy a jet yes
okay
and
the only thing they do is fly their
family on vacation
they cannot write the jet off at all
yes but if they use it for business a
hundred percent for business they can
write it off a hundred percent okay but
it's the same thing with the truck yes
it's the same thing with a computer yeah
but to save on taxes like but the
write-off it's still but you're still
buying yeah
dream
yeah pricing and there are there are
there are a few items in the current tax
law that's shifting very rapidly that
can all be written off in one year
okay and a jet happens so was my guy
right on instagram
no he's not because in the same vein
still if you spend ten million dollars
on a jet yeah okay and you use it a
hundred percent for business yeah and
you write off a hundred percent of the
ten million dollars
you still only saved
if you're in a forty percent tax bracket
then you still only say four million
dollars
no if it's not the full still spent ten
yep and saved four yep now the check
cost you a little less after taxes sure
but just like the truckload
it's not free you need to go spend more
money to save money is mathematical
horse crap
whether you put millions on it or ten
thousand dollars we need it that's the
bow we needed america there it is right
there mathematical horse crap we're not
sure what that is but all right this is
the ramsey show